uh do you think threads is gonna be the
Twitter killer oh okay no we can't talk
about this why can't we talk it's boring
is it boring yeah it's not gonna but
Twitter's a mess and it's whatever and I
think we're on it I don't know I do I do
love it have you guys started the
threads yeah I have I have yeah I do
love all of the little Jabs that Elon is
making to Mark Zuckerberg on Twitter
it's just it's like it's like watching
two children fighting it's a mess
Twitter actually sucks to use yeah
Twitter should not get I remember using
a way less yeah yeah it's it's it's it's
such a weird feeling because I started
my threads like literally today because
for some reason I couldn't log in when I
was in America
um and then it was just like logging on
and just seeing people post and I'm like
oh my God this doesn't feel like a
cesspool yeah I feel like he's like the
old school Twitter yeah it's it's this
is what I felt when I started my Twitter
yeah and it kind of made me realize that
I'm fine throwing away all of the
followers that I've built up over the
years because you know there's you know
it's it's kind of like
it's it's it's kind of like I've been on
Twitter since when did you guys start
your Twitter I think I started mine like
2011 or something I think mine was 2014.
yeah
um 120
2009 yeah 2009 2009. wait you had one
before YouTube yeah I had one oh I made
one because everyone was like you need a
Twitter if you're a YouTuber yeah okay I
never even touched it yeah but my name
was like because I was obsessed with
Hannah Montana at that time and I only
made it to follow the following Miley
Cyrus to follow like I wanted to know
what the cast was up to you know cool
then I realized that [__] it's boring
as [__] and so I didn't do anything with
that but I've had it since 2009 because
I actually got locked out of my Twitter
account
uh I don't know if you do you remember
this my Twitter account I was I couldn't
access it for like four or five days
yeah because when I made it I obviously
lied about my date of birth because I
was actually like I was like 11. when I
made Twitter yeah like when I made
Twitter it was still like well I mean
that's not really old it's still the
favorites it wasn't hot yeah it was like
star yeah and I yeah so I made it
literally I don't know when it's really
come out what was the year it came out
Kyle can you check
um yes in 2009 I think I was very very
very in the start of it
um
okay so like three years in yeah uh and
I think this is still even my space for
the thing so I'm like but yeah so
uh how old was I in 2009 uh 14 years ago
so I was 12. 12 when I made it right
which is crazy to think right uh I made
it and then um my date of birth actually
lied yeah yeah you know when you're 12
you're just getting the habit of lying
on these websites yeah well of course uh
you have to you can't go into any
website and not be like how else are you
supposed to see the 18 plus you just lie
so I was just so in tune with lying and
I still kind of do it sometimes I'm like
[__] I'm gonna tell my real ones yeah
I'm long I'm 50. yeah yeah what of it uh
so I made it when I was 12 and then I
had the genius idea uh like four years
ago it's performing Japan it was like a
year before yes four years ago and five
years ago I guess five years ago I had
this genius idea I was like you know
what it's time to set the record
straight let's put my real date of birth
in because it was like March 5th or
something is my birthday on Twitter and
people would be like oh it's happy
birthday oh no it's on my boots yeah
it's a fake birthday yeah so
changed it to my real birthday
immediately got locked out of my Twitter
what couldn't use it because Twitter has
a policy where they block accounts
didn't know this that even if you're 18
or 19 now or whatever they they will
still shut your account down because it
was made under the
um when it wasn't allowed right yeah
right
um so you just like self-report yeah and
tell Twitter that you [__] up and so I
was like [__] and I I Googled about this
happened to a bunch of people yeah and
it's pretty much impossible to get your
account back but at this point I had
like I think 100K followers I was like
holy [__] I spent years building this up
what the [__] and I had to have that Sea
Dog VA and everything I was like yeah
yeah I need this back and so I submit
there was a few people online who had
some lock and because Twitter support
was and still is absolutely [__]
useless and garbage it's all automated
yeah yeah you could send in an ID uh but
it couldn't be it was so busted that it
couldn't be a it couldn't be a
non-american D otherwise the system they
had wouldn't recognize it right so I had
to ask someone so I asked my editor at
the time I was like Hey can I have your
ID to put in and so now Twitter just
thinks I'm that age but I had to send
because apparently someone was saying
Twitter the Twitter thing is so bad
it's always been bad that someone could
submit one at this time and two weeks
later someone could submit it and the
person that two weeks later could get
seen first for no [__] apparent
reason yeah so I made like I did like 50
email accounts and submitted all the
same [__] and it was something like the
40th one was the one that got like
approved and then my account got changed
this American ID so Twitter thinks I'm
like 30 something
crazy oh so yeah I don't know I'm sure a
lot of people would believe you if you
actually said yeah so yeah so if Twitter
asks it it's such a dumb [__] rule
what a dumb rule yeah to block I think I
think it was something to do with one of
the government laws or something I don't
know what it was it was it was [__]
stupid either way well that's what you
get for learning either way I'm just
waiting don't give a [__] about threads
I'm on it I'm vibing with it right now
but I don't expect it to be a big thing
well the problem is why why don't you
expect it to be a big thing uh well I
don't know because right now it's it's
using elon's gonna bring down the band
Hammer uh that's what people is no
thinking is gonna happen it's like oh
lawsuit incoming I think that Instagram
serves a really good purpose and reaches
an audience that Twitter definitely
doesn't but I think people who want
threads would just still use Twitter in
a way and I don't think the at least
right now it's not great but I think it
maybe it will in future but I don't know
I think right now there's like zero
there's like zero algorithm on threads
right there yeah where like I I remember
yesterday I was like scrolling through
it and I'm just like I don't follow any
of these people why are they showing up
yeah I I think I think like whether it
whether it like becomes a thing or not
really much depends on will people
continue using Twitter because I want to
post on Twitter as much as I can because
it's good for my like online [__]
brand and all this [__] because you know
we're like [__] influencers and all
that [__] but like I just don't I just
find myself not wanting to not because
it's a conscious choice just because I
just don't find it fun no tutors also
like only quote Retreats right now you
know yes yeah it's literally just all
you do on Twitter now is that it's just
these like five accounts and they're in
everyone's feed and all they do is scour
the web for [__] tiny ass posts so
they can dunk on someone yeah and that's
literally the entire website and it's so
[__] boring and it sucks it's just
tiring you know it was fun like the
first few times and then you just see
like a random person catching Strays and
like everybody's trying to quote like
ratio each other and call retweet and
it's like this yeah it sucks yeah yeah
exactly so it's just nice yeah it's so
negative so it's just nice going on like
[__] threads and just seeing people
trying to start like a new it's it's
like a new exciting thing the moment I
saw like every tweet or I guess a
re-thread yeah I don't know what the
[__] word for it is but like just
seeing like an actual positive rethread
I was like oh my God I miss this I know
same here wait people
retweeting not for malicious intention
yeah but just to share something cool
what the [__] yeah yeah so so far I'm
really enjoying threads just because
again it kind of gives me back that old
school feel of Twitter but yeah
obviously it's still got a lot of work
to do because it is still so new and
like obviously there's like zero
algorithm or any kind of like once they
on way of going around unbanned porn
it's it's over so at the moment they
release the anime titties it's over I
[__] I [__] tweeted that or
threaded out that [__] I've just like
release the titties
come on Zack release the titties bro I
was gonna just dick out for Elon sound
yeah